and by the way he was begged to come
back to the company last year when it
was facing a tough time there was a
sense that reddit needed to be saved and
that you'd lost connection with users
and and moderators what have you done to
change that and how is it going well a
lot of it is just doing the the natural
thing honestly I feel like we don't have
to think too hard about it it's because
I'm a part of the community I know that
community I was as a user when I wasn't
at reddit I was also angry at some of
the things that were going on I felt
like reddit hadn't hadn't built some
obvious things right our moderators were
angry they needed better tooling there
is lots of community issues tricky ones
that required a lot of attention so
since I've been back the main focus has
been on let's just fix the acute pace
there's a ton a ton of low-hanging fruit
we don't actually have to be that
creative we just have to do the in my
opinion with the obvious sensible things
are so what about the less obvious
things you've said there are more
changes coming what else is in store
well okay so some of the obvious ones
right building on mobile like half our
users are mobile but we actually don't
have mobile apps so that's that's a no
brainer but the more subtle ones our
front page algorithm has a long way to
go I think reddit has grown so much
since we started it you only started
that we only had one community now we
have hundred thousand communities the
algorithms haven't actually kept up with
some of those developments so I think
there's a lot of things we can do there
to help all of our users which the user
base is much broader now find the things
that they're looking for what about the
hate and the harassment problems and the
I can just imagine a string in relation
to this particular interview people just
upset that we're knowledge in yes well
those are really tricky issues and so
when I came back actually I came back
and I had this plan if we're going to
draw a crystal clear line of what's
acceptable and not and the big lesson I
learned is that's actually impossible to
do wherever we draw the line there will
be our troll users they'll be just the
bad users standing right up against that
line and so I've gotten comfortable the
fact that just like in the real world
there will always be things on reddit
that we're on
with what is important to us is making
sure that other reddit users feel feel
like they're welcome right and so what I
feel much much thousands of users I mean
how do you make them all happy well so
we don't have an obligation to make
everybody happy or even not offended but
not abused is a big one so policing user
behavior is actually something we're
doing much much better at we've built a
bunch of new content policies and
release those and now the next step is
just enforcing them at scale which is
more of a technology problem but
technology problems are something we're
really comfortable with actually
responding to all of our reports and you
know dealing with things that way now
when it comes to the actual tricky
content like the content that I
personally are we person at the company
don't want to see their those
conversations are much longer so when
you're thinking about the changes that
you have planned how does reddit look
differently let's say two years from now
than it does today what what things you
there's the subreddit feature there's
the front page so one of the challenges
we have right now is we have two classes
of users we have a class of users that
we would call the redditors that get
reddit they know how deep it is how
broad it is how magical it is they
participate in many different
communities and then we have a bigger
chunk of users probably at any point
we've probably seen every
english-speaking Internet user at some
point but we don't always grab ahold of
them you know they come to reddit they
consume whatever content they were
linked to and then they leave we have a
bunch of users who for example think
reddit is the largest sports forum which
they work very well be but you know
there's so much more to it so the big
challenge on my mind is how do we expose
those users to all of the other facets
of reddits that all of the other facets
of their personalities would you know
find a home how much are you thinking
about monetizing read it and and you
know not just bringing it back to where
it was in terms of traffic but turning
this into a sustainable business so
there's a short-term view which is in my
mind the answer is probably about twenty
percent of my time it's something that
we should be paying attention to we
should be growing revenue revenue is
growing but revenue is not going to make
or break this company in the next couple
of years
we know at our scale we should be making
a lot more money but historically it's
not something that reddits really
thought about what is really important
to our business though is can we engage
these users can we give them a home on
mobile that's productive can we acquire
new users in you know different
languages in different countries so
those are the things that keep me up
that night right now monetization will
spend will do the obvious things we'd be
a fool not to but we don't need to be
creative about it for quite a while